what's carlson doing  should be lost king b2 knight c3  or knight c3 first yeah this has gone  horribly wrong  okay  now it's time to see get pushing  looks like he might be steaming a little  bit after the loss against wesley he's  avoided repetitions really tried to  crush vichy with black  the old tiger  is  just quietly taking all his stuff  it looks well on track to win here okay  i mean is it that clear-cut because  after all black will get the h pawn and  now isn't this eight pawn just  yep too fast  it is  it does resign he does resign i'm not  sure which ones i think he lost some  time yeah  wow two losses in a row for magnus  no not good news for